I had this desire for dance I never
really took it seriously about the age
of 10 and the studio owners were I'm
gonna take it seriously who would take
it so it takes it seriously at my age
yes I know
I mean you can't I think that's how you
get through things yeah no no exactly
and I think the studio owners were
coming up to my mom being like we don't
think Larson dances for Larson she's you
know all over the place she has too much
energy definitely like ADHD there's
something going on here so my mom was
like well you know if you're not you
know she'll she'll prove you wrong and
my mom was just like Larson like where
do you want to take this like do you
want to take this seriously like is
dance
um you know a profession that you want
to go into